health investigators are trying to
figure out how some Minnesota children
contracted a rare illness with polio
like symptoms at least six children in
Minnesota have been diagnosed and
hospitalized with listen to this acute
flaccid myelitis in September 20th on
the average the Minnesota Department of
Health sees only about one of those
cases per year Jamie yuccas spoke to one
affected family she's at the Minnesota
Department of Health in st. Paul was
more on this story Jamie this is very
scary stuff good morning to you yes many
parents very concerned Gail good morning
to use state and federal health workers
are trying to determine the cause of
this disease since 2014 there have been
360 cases reported throughout the United
States but for one Minneapolis boy his
symptoms started showing up after he
started recovering from the common cold
I said hey buddy
can you lift your right arm and he goes
I can't Elaine and Michael Young said
soon after their now four-year-old son
Orville developed a fever in July he
started losing mobility in his right arm
you feel it buddy
the young say doctors ran several tests
but only got closer to a diagnosis after
a second MRI and the results come back
that he he had an abnormality through
his entire spinal cord Orville was
diagnosed with acute flaccid myelitis or
AFM and spent six days in the hospital
at his worst
the young say Orville was unable to move
the upper part of his right arm and had
difficulty moving his legs and sitting
on his felt so sad for him that this
thing we couldn't that we didn't know
about and we couldn't protect him from
had happened and had taken a lot away
from him since mid-september six
children under the age of 10 were
hospitalized and diagnosed with AF M in
Minnesota one possible way it can
develop is from a viral infection it's
very very rare and it's about one in a
million
Chris ears men with the Minnesota
Department of Health says AFM affects
the spinal cord symptoms can include
limb weakness facial drooping and
trouble swallowing or speaking if you
have a child that is
these kind of symptoms they should be
seen evaluated immediately the young say
Orville has regained most of his muscle
function except in his upper right arm
they don't know if he'll be able to move
it again how confusing is this to him
you know he's a trooper it's remarkably
like able to wrap his head around this
as it's going on you know he's kind of
like one day at a time whereas we're
worried about the whole rest of his life
Orville is in therapy and could need
surgery later but doctors don't know a
lot about AFM right now so there are no
specific treatment options available
health workers say one way to prevent
this disease is to stay healthy they
recommend washing your hands and being
up to date on vaccinations flat alright
Jamie yuccas thank you very much Jamie